kickoff reporter Constantine stuva
traveled to Frankfurt to meet Sebastian
hoda and find out how he's doing the
footballers not renewing his contract at
Frankfurt and has set his sights on
moving to a bigger club hoda at 23 years
old is yet another young and talented
player whose ambition has outgrown his
surroundings how's he feeling just ahead
of the big leap what's motivating him to
leave an area he knows so well and will
the move change how he sees home kickoff
asked him those questions and more what
your friends and family say about you
leaving Frankfurt 11 um my name wasn't
even build my mother's a bit sad because
she won't see me as often but in the
football business you only have 15 years
to achieve everything possible than yeah
and part of that is switching clubs from
time to time so if you remove fish are
dying in infancy neon regrets are not a
tool that's my 14 and excellent and fun
day all I can do is assure her that
she's always welcome to visit whenever
she wants to my friends would also of
course prefer if I stayed here but
they're all studying and don't know
where their lives will take them off by
the ends or from DN so changes are
probably in store for some of them to
finish down or no flesh oh no can you
imagine being happier anywhere in the
world than here in Frankfurt thankful
that's not good morning it's hard to
imagine because I feel so comfortable
and it easier thank you but I think it's
a growing-up process for me to move
somewhere else and try to settle in and
fit into a different environment in
another city for me it's an exciting
challenge and commissioners Randolph car
these are missing why do you want the
challenge and yeah let's what's complete
another because it's something
completely different well I think it's
something completely different from the
familiar I've never lived away from my
family for a long time before
Pancham are now whenever I want to go
and visit my parents it's a journey of
20 minutes or a quarter of an hour that
would be possible anymore it's a no home
I'll also have to meet new people make
new friends and build up a new life of
sorts perspectiva somebody of us got off
the bomb incident leaves someone who
strives for change for adventure the
show nation it's an expert eat of
definitely not adventure both but
there's nothing wrong with seeing
something else in life lame within our
linseed and I'm really looking forward
to doing that and to having that
experience we'll see how it goes and
mother in this is oscar for you see
inertia which don't publish it but his i
haven't yet experienced inertia in my
young life like its marked so i don't
really know how it feels mr. Shanahan
friends older I was always moving
forward and now in football too before
that in school and that's set to
continue one yeah swing good so hits
right again Savannah honey she'll
probably change have you thought about
how you will change as a person than the
possibility that one day you will return
home and be a different person that's
the event see my own fam you don't know
i'm at so we can land i'm interested
goodbye it's not kneeling earth i've
never been away for a long time i did
notice with school friends of mine who
spent a year abroad they had changed
became more grown-up box negra ones and
but i hope that i don't change to the
point that i forget my roots after or
that I don't keep my feet on the ground
I hope that never happens mana woodland
at mckenna or a supervisor dead malcolm
born bleib i'll just just for fish just
as net off conf opposite glom she
doesn't groups india would you find it
easy to socialize my strange place and
quickly be able to find a new group of
friends um stringdusters does finish
make you think i'll be able to do it
watch create but it's difficult to say
because I've never done it before our
money model but if you're open to
another kind of life and I think it is
possible on sunday is trying to sell my
gosh hey water Sebastian Rhoda wherever
you end up in the summer I wish you
all the best I'm already looking forward
to seeing you play somewhere else and
soon we'll find out where I was good
thank you